artificial intelligence is was topic
history on projects in i everyone welcome
you simply learn before moving on please make
sir you subscribe to simply learns
youtube channel and press the bell icon you never
miss any updates let us define
artificial intelligence first
artificial intelligence is a technology of
Turning a computer based robot to work and
act like humans now let me list
out important air projects for you
face detection system it is a form of
biometric recognition
is called facial recognition people can be identity
sources to run face detection
this technology is mostly employed in
security and law and enforcement open and is the
best technology to create it now
python packet called open and is made
specifically to address computer vision
jobs computer vision is an process
used in the processing of images by
computer it is concern with the deep
understanding of digital  Photos of film it is
necessary to atomic operations that
can be performed by human visual systems that for a
computer should be able to identify
items like a statue or an M post or even the
face of a human being second van it bot it is the
best  Idea if you have
chosen chart bot aaj your project topic this will make your resume more
effective in
case you are looking for a job
80% of de business
plus aur php as un programming
language tu developer chart designing and
building nlp chart parts tha accept
speech  And text data is made is made by
dialog flue you can go through
in projects to get d rough idea there r
in platform which will help you to build a chatbot
regardless of how excellent your
chat bot is there is always
room for development d final start
Developers constantly and laugh their birds
over the time using Eye and machine learning
Social media recommendation system This of web
service like Netflix Amazon and
YouTube had increased the use of
recommendable systems in our daily life the
r algorithm that insist users in
finding information that is pertinent  You
DM recommend on systems are important
but same form science they can generate a lot of
income or you too set yourself apart from
rivals in order to provide recommendation it
evaluate de relationship between de
user and de object further well
ahead de palace between users and positions
Coming too predicting stop
this application is widely
applicable everywhere aage are career s parents van will
love to develop stock prediction
applications today it is full of data this
project would be ideal for students who want to
work in the finance industry because
it can provide a  Repeat because it can provide dem ab
gathered understanding
of various aspects of de field coming to
medical diagnosis this project is advantages from a
medical stand point
a I proudest can be created to
detect hard base diseases and also
detect cancer it is intended to offer
patients with  heart illness online medical
advice guidance after processing d data
this system will search d database for any
analysis date may be connected to d given dts using
data meaning techniques this
intelligence system determines d disease date d patient information
most conclusively
dismbers
based on d system diagnosis dosar  Can then
speak with qualified medical
professionals users of de system can also view information about
various doctors
coming to you and important project date is
search engine
Solutions to any questions you have and
give is pretty significant in
modern search engines because on lot of
language processing tax place date python is the
widely used language to
develop any search engine search engine is manly
confined with lots and lots of data it is
helpful for  any i carrier s
next is virtual assistant to
assist user wahi do you need virtual
assistant in your device when your
building your on it is also interesting
for me develop it
balls nlp and data meaning voice
based virtual assistant are popular today because they make
life easier  For users and give
this is your life you understand human
language in order to construct this
system and any voice command is received this
system translate it in machine language and
store these command in its database hate speech
detection in social media automated hits
bhi detection an un  Krishna weapon in d fight against hate speech
propaganda specially on
social media for d job in techniques have bin develop
without including any recent
exploration of deep learning based system
for d objective of detecting head number
of techniques have bin investigated including
conventional classified
classified based on deep learning  And
combination of both of dam on de our hand and
number of data set benz marks including
twitter sentiment analysis have
bin introduced and made available for d
evolution of de performance of this
algorithm and d lasting house price you will need to estimate
de se price of  An
brand new home in any other place for this
assignment d data set for this project includes
information on d cost of homes
in various city neighborhoods d same machine
learning repository is d place where you make find
d data set needed for
disratures you will also received respect  Data
set with information on d age of d
population d cities prime rate and d
location of non retail enterprises in addition to d
pricing of various residencies it is an
excellent project to
test your knowledge if you are un up today c mention
date r in different branches  of I
h employing an different set of method
and technique this is an good thing for a
beginner science you can select d project
date is interesting to you and not very about being able to
implement all of d
different techniques and method hope you enjoy
watching d  video thank you for
watching stat
tune for more from simply learn til give happy learning he there if you like this
video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube channel
and click here to watch similar video